pay Sena files Jezebel is hitting
theaters this week the film follows a
young woman who returns to her childhood
home after surviving a car accident only
to be tormented by a spirit that's been
awaiting her return here are five other
houses and movies we would not want to
spend the night in number five The
Amityville Horror George and Kathy Lutz
moved their family into one one two
Ocean Avenue completely unaware of the
property's chilling past there's more
than a bad fly infestation to deal with
it's the unseen visitors who lend a
possessive hand to ruining your mental
well-being that you really have to watch
out for you know it's time to leave when
the walls start bleeding 28 days after
the Lutz family moved into their dream
house running for their lives
number 4 house nobuhiko Abby yeah she's
simply an aptly titled film has become a
cult classic since its 1977 release when
a school girl named gorgeous brings six
of her classmates to visit her aunt's
home for a summer trip none could have
predicted the bizarre events that follow
from a man-eating piano to imprisonment
within a grandfather clock what could be
more terrifying than a domestic space
filled with household objects that have
it out for you
this treasure would have been hard to
track down if it weren't inducted into
the Criterion Collection in 2010 number
3 poltergeist perhaps the most unnerving
element of the suburban home and the
Steven Spielberg produced horror classic
is how unthreatening and normal it
appears to be but one night under this
roof could leave you a victim to a demon
tree doors to other dimensions and the
dangers of sitting too close to the
television set
if nothing else poltergeist has taught
us to make sure any property we purchase
has no history of being cemetery grounds
number 2 House of 1000 corpses 2 couples
interested in pursuing urban legends and
roadside attractions get way more than
they bargained for when they stumble
upon a statistic family of serial
killers in Rob Zombie's directorial
debut as if the film's title weren't
repellant enough each family member has
a strange definition of hospitality from
feeding you agatha krispies for
breakfast to carving you up for the sake
of art zombie was heavily influenced by
the likes of the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
and The Hills Have Eyes somehow managing
to create a space even more unpleasant
to be in
[Music]
number one Jew on the grudge after a
cruel bout of domestic violence a
vengeful spirit is formed bent on
pursuing and haunting any who entered
the Tokyo home even if you survived a
single night at the house in Juwan the
curse carrying ghosts would follow you
to your inevitable end
Juwan played a big role in bringing
j-horror to the 21st century
takashi shimizu directed an American
remake of his own film two years later
with The Grudge these are just five of
countless movie houses we wouldn't want
to be caught dead in
we know you have some in mind so please
share and discuss in the comments below
thanks for watching
Oh